Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. The judges of this state may tranquilly condemn us for our conduct at that time, but history, the goddess of a higher truth and a better legal code, will smile as she tears up this verdict and will acquit us all of the crime for which this verdict demands punishment. But history will then also summon before its own tribunal those who, invested with power today, have trampled on law and justice, condemning our people to misery and ruin, and who,
感谢收听《历史其余部分》。要想收听每周独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。本州的法官们当时可以心安理得地为我们的行为判刑，但作为更高真理与更好法典女神的历史，将在撕碎这份判决书时报以微笑，并宣告我们所有人无罪——而本案判决本要求为之惩罚我们。然而，历史随后也将把那些今天大权在握、践踏法律与正义、将我们的人民判处苦难与毁灭，并在
in the hour of their country's misfortune, took more account of their own egos than of the life of the community. That was failed postcard artist, former corporal in the Bavarian army and leader of the Nazi party, Adolf Hitler, defending himself at his trial in the spring of 1924, attempting to overthrow the Weimar Republic. And Dominic, in the first part of our epic sweep through the rise of the Nazis, we looked at the background to the emergence of the Nazi party. And the Beer Hall Putsch is a kind of famous way marker in that story. And we'll come to that. But before we do that, let's look at the background to the Beer Hall Putsch and to Hitler's contempt for the legal and political structure that are
国家不幸的时刻，比起共同体的生命更在乎自我私利的人，传唤至其自身的法庭受审。这是曾经落第的明信片画家、巴伐利亚军队前下士、纳粹党领袖阿道夫·希特勒，于1924年春天在企图推翻魏玛共和国的审判中为自己进行辩护。多米尼克，在我们宏大审视纳粹崛起历程的第一部分中，我们探讨了纳粹党崛起的背景。啤酒馆政变正是这段故事中一个颇具名气的路标。我们稍后会讲到这一点。但在那之前，让我们先来看看啤酒馆政变背后的背景，以及希特勒对当时
governing Germany at this time. And those structures are kind of basically summed up by that phrase, Weimar Republic. So what is the Weimar Republic? Where's Weimar? What's going on? Okay. Big questions, Tom. So yes. Hello, everybody. We left Hitler last time, didn't we? At the beginning of the 1920s, the head of this very small, frankly, quite cranky political party in Munich, not a major national force by any means. I mean, Hitler, a former nobody who has found his voice. And I suppose, Tom, it would be fair to say that without the weakness of the Weimar Republic, there is no Third Reich, there is no national socialist tyranny,
统治德国的法律与政治架构的蔑视。而这些架构基本上可以用“魏玛共和国”这个词来概括。那么，什么是魏玛共和国？魏玛在哪里？发生了什么？好吧，汤姆，这是个重大问题。所以，是的。大家好，我们上次讲到希特勒，对吧？在20世纪20年代初，他是慕尼黑这个非常小的、坦率地说相当古怪的政党的党魁，绝不是什么全国性的主流力量。我的意思是，希特勒只是一个找到了自己声音的前无名小卒。我想，汤姆，客观地说，如果没有魏玛共和国的软弱，就不会有第三帝国，就不会有国家社会主义暴政，
there's nothing of that kind. And the question that therefore hangs over this episode of the podcast is, is the failure of the Weimar Republic inevitable? Is it doomed from the very beginning? I mean, one issue is that nobody really had sort of set out to create it or wanted to set it up. So last time we talked about the end of the First World War in Germany, how it all happened so suddenly in the early days of November 1918. You know, in a matter of a handful of days, there are mutinies and rebellions and uprisings. The Kaiser disappears off into exile. Their governing structures seem to fall apart.
就不会有诸如此类的事情。因此，悬在这个播客本期节目之上的问题是：魏玛共和国的失败是不可避免的吗？它从一开始就注定要灭亡吗？我的意思是，问题之一在于，其实没有人真正着手去创建它，或者想要建立它。所以上次我们谈到了德国第一次世界大战的结局，以及它在1918年11月初发生得是多么突然。你知道，在短短几天之内，就发生了哗变、叛乱和起义。威廉二世流亡海外。他们的统治架构似乎土崩解瓦。
And amid all this chaos, the man who's really emblematic of the Weimar Republic, Friedrich Ebert, who is the leader of the SPD, the Social Democratic Party, he basically seizes the moment to try and create a new structure. And he does that actually not because he desperately wants to, but because he was a monarchist. He famously said to Prince Max of Baden, he hated the idea of a social and political revolution. He said, I hate it like sin. But also, Dominic, isn't the reason why it's in Weimar, which is the hometown of Go48. So this liberal tradition. Ebert is leader of the Social Democrats,
而在所有这些混乱中，真正象征魏玛共和国的那个人——社民党（社会民主党）领袖弗里德里希·艾伯特，基本上抓住了这个时机试图建立一个新的架构。他这么做其实并不是因为他多么渴望这样做，而是因为他是个保皇党人。他曾对巴登的马克斯亲王说过一句话很有名的话，他厌恶社会与政治革命。他说：“我恨它如罪孽。”但同时，多米尼克，它之所以在魏玛——也就是歌德的故乡——难道不是因为这种自由主义传统吗？艾伯特是社民党的领袖，
but he is not a sort of hardcore Marxist or a hardcore revolutionary or anything of the kind. Not in any way a Fuhrer. No, you could almost see him as a kind of German Clement Attlee for our British listeners. So he's very patriotic. He's very sort of pragmatic. He makes an alliance with the Centre Party,
但他并不是那种强硬的马克思主义者、强硬的革命者或类似的人物。绝不是什么元首。不，对于我们的英国听众来说，你几乎可以把他看作是一个德国的克莱门特·艾德礼。所以他非常爱国。他非常务实。他在1918至1919年间与中央党——
which is the Catholic Party, and with the Liberals in 1918-19, and with the army, and with the army high command. They all agree, listen, the threat of revolution amid the shock of defeat is so great. We have to get this thing together,
也就是天主教政党——以及自由派、军队和陆军最高指挥部结成了联盟。他们一致认为，在战败的冲击下，革命的威胁是如此之大。我们必须把这个国家拼凑起来，
stabilize it. So they meet in Weimar, which, as you say, is identified with the greatest German writer, Goethe. And they put together a constitution for this republic. And the constitution, it's against the backdrop of all that fighting and the Spartacist uprising, as you mentioned, Rosa Luxemburg and Marxists being shot out of hand and stuff. So Dominic, Michael Burley, another of the great British
使之稳定。于是他们在魏玛开会。如你所说，魏玛与伟大的德国作家歌德联系在一起。他们为这个共和国制定了一部宪法。这部宪法是在所有这些战斗以及斯巴达克团起义的背景下诞生的，正如你提到的，罗莎·卢森堡和马克思主义者遭到就地枪决等等。所以，多米尼克，迈克尔·伯利——另一位研究这段历史的伟大英国
historians of this, he has a brilliant description for the mood in Germany. He describes it as a dreadful mass sentimentality compounded of anger, fear, resentment, and self-pity. And that's a brilliant way of summing up the background against which the founders of the Weimar Republic are working and the kind of headwinds that they're moving into. Yes. And actually, would those headwinds have been different in France or Britain had we lost the First World War? I don't think they would, actually. I think if it had been a similarly shattering experience that we would have had exactly the same blend or at least a similar blend in London or in Paris. So the constitution
历史学家，对德国当时的心态有一个极好的描述。他将其描述为一种由愤怒、恐惧、怨恨和自怜交织而成的可怕大众感伤主义。这是对魏玛共和国缔造者们当时所处的工作背景以及他们正在迎头面对的逆境的一种极妙的总结。是的。事实上，如果我们英国或法国在第一次世界大战中战败，这些逆境会有所不同吗？其实我觉得不会。我认为，如果那是一次同样具有毁灭性的经历，我们在伦敦或巴黎也绝对会有完全相同的混合情绪，或者至少是类似的混合情绪。所以，他们想出的这部宪法
they come up with is a little bit like Bismarck's Reich. The army and the president are sort of set slightly apart from democratic politics. The president has this power. He has these emergency powers under what's called Article 48 of the constitution. If necessary, he can rule by decree and use the army to enforce his will. But in normal times, it will be the Reichstag,
有点像俾斯麦的德意志帝国。军队和总统在某种程度上与民主政治保持一点距离。总统拥有这种权力。根据宪法所谓的第四十八条，他拥有这些紧急权力。如有必要，他可以颁布法令进行统治，并利用军队来强制执行他的意志。但在正常时期，将由帝国议会——
the Assembly, the Parliament, who've been the majority in the Reichstag, who basically control the government. Now, even at this point, because it's born in such chaos, Ebert uses this emergency power a lot. He uses it 136 times, in fact, always saying there's so much disorder. I have to use it. I have to step in. I have to use the army, which I think often he does, actually, to be quite frank, because there's so much chaos. The problem, of course, is that that establishes a precedent, which is that basically the Reichstag and the president are set against each other. And if necessary, the president will always intervene against the wishes of democratic politicians.
也就是议会、国会——中占据多数的议员来基本上控制政府。现在，甚至在这个时候，由于它是诞生于如此混乱的局势中，艾伯特大量使用了这种紧急权力。事实上，他使用了136次，总是说有这么多的混乱。我必须使用它。我必须介入。我必须使用军队。坦率地说，我觉得他经常这么做，其实是因为有太多的混乱。当然，问题在于，这确立了一个先例，那就是帝国议会和总统基本上是对立的。如果有必要，总统总是会干预并违背民主政治家的意愿。
But again, that's very much an inheritance from before the war. It is indeed. It is indeed. But the difference is that everybody thought that the Wilhelmine state was legitimate. Nobody ever questioned whether the Kaiser's Reich was a legitimate expression of German politics. But the Weimar Republic is absolutely tainted from the very beginning because, of course, it's associated with defeat. It's a product of defeat. So Germany has not just been defeated
但话又说回来，这很大程度上是继承自战前。确实如此。确实如此。但不同之处在于，每个人都认为威廉二世时期的国家是合法的。没有人会去质疑德皇的帝国是否是德国政治的合法表现。但魏玛共和国从一开始就带有绝对的污点，因为理所当然地，它与战败联系在一起。它是战败的产物。所以德国不仅在
in the First World War, it's lost 13% of its national territory. So Alsace-Lorraine, the Saarland becomes sort of French protectorate, the Rhineland is demilitarized. It's lost Western Poland, which is now part of the new Polish Republic. The Germans feel outraged at that. They're outraged because they say the Allies are a load of hypocrites and liars because the Allies go around talking about self-determination, but they won't let the Austrian Germans join with the other Germans in Germany. So everybody, both in Austria and in Germany, is very upset at that.
第一次世界大战中战败了，它还失去了13%的领土。阿尔萨斯-洛林割让了，萨尔兰变成了某种法国保护领，莱茵兰非军事化了。它失去了西普鲁士，也就是现在新波兰共和国的一部分。德国人对此感到无比愤怒。他们感到愤怒，是因为他们说盟国是一群伪君子和骗子，因为盟国到处高谈阔论民族自决，却不允许奥地利的德国人与德国的其他德国人合并。因此，无论是奥地利还是德国，每个人对此都非常不满。
Because the problem for France and Britain and the Allies generally is that Germany remains potentially the richest and therefore the most militarily significant power in Central Europe. And so to allow a defeated Germany to end up with an even larger population would obviously totally go against, but of course it's hypocrisy. It's pure hypocrisy. Agreed. I mean, that's why Austria exists to this day. Austria wouldn't otherwise exist.
因为对法国、英国以及整个盟国来说，问题在于德国依然有潜力成为中欧最富有、因而在军事上也最重要的强国。因此，允许一个战败的德国最终拥有更加庞大的国民人口，显然会完全违背这一点——但当然，这就是伪装的虚伪。纯粹的虚伪。完全同意。我的意思是，这就是奥地利至今仍然存在的原因。否则奥地利就不会存在了。
They also, as you said, that terror of German power. So there are strict limits on the German army and navy. They can't have tanks. They can't have artillery. They can only have 100,000 men. The Germans are very offended by this. They think it's sort of unsporting. They're not being allowed to compete, as it were.
如你所说，他们对德国的力量也充满恐惧。因此，对德国陆军和海军有着严格的限制。他们不能拥有坦克。他们不能拥有火炮。他们只能拥有十万人的军队。德国人对此感到非常被冒犯。他们认为这很不体育。他们好像不被允许参与竞争一样。
And, of course, the Germans have to pay reparations. They have to accept that they were guilty for the First World War, and they have to pay 132 billion gold marks, as well as loads of coal and hand over loads of railway engines and ships. Now, some people listening to this podcast will say, well, the Germans were guilty of the First World War. Not all historians would say that. And you can bet your bottom dollar, very, very few Germans would have said that at the end of the First World War.
而且，当然，德国人必须支付战争赔款。他们必须承认自己对第一次世界大战负有罪责，并且必须支付1320亿金马克，同时还要交出大量的煤炭，以及上交大量的火车头和船只。听这个播客的一些人可能会说，嗯，德国人确实对第一次世界大战负有罪责。并非所有历史学家都会这么说。而且你可以打包票，在第一次世界大战结束时，极少极少的德国人会这么说。
And so the only explanation, therefore, for lots of Germans, patriotic Germans, to explain what's happening is that the people who have signed up to this, the Weimar politicians, are traitors, that they are complicit in the stab in the back. Exactly right. Because as we said last time, a lot of Germans just didn't see the defeat coming. They had been told right up to the end that they were winning the war. And they thought when their army had launched that great offensive in 1918, this is going to win us the war. Then when it doesn't work out, they are shocked and surprised, and the only explanation seems to be betrayal.
因此，对于许多德国人、爱国德国人来说，要解释正在发生的事情，唯一的解释就是：那些签署了这一切的人、魏玛的政治家们是叛徒，他们是“背后捅刀子”阴谋的同谋。完全正确。正如我们上次所说，许多德国人根本没有预料到战败的到来。他们直到最后都被告知他们正在赢得战争。当他们的军队在1918年发起那场伟大的攻势时，他们以为这将为我们赢得战争。然后，当结果并非如此时，他们感到震惊和意外，唯一的解释似乎就是背叛。
A key problem in this, by the way, is that the army commanders, particularly General Ludendorff, went around telling everybody that they'd been stabbed in the back, which Ludendorff must have known was a lie, you know, to cover themselves, because they don't want to admit we were just beaten, plain and square. So that's a huge issue for Weimar. In fact, the army generally is never very reliable in supporting us. So the army still keeps its old sort of Kaiser's colors of black, red, and white.
顺便说一句，这里的一个关键问题是，军队指挥官，尤其是埃里希·鲁登道夫将军，到处跟人说他们是在背后被捅了一刀。鲁登道夫肯定知道这是一个谎言，你知道的，这是为了掩盖他们自己，因为他们不想承认我们就是堂堂正正、彻彻底底地被打败了。所以这对魏玛来说是一个巨大的问题。事实上，军队总体上在支持我们这件事上从来都不是很靠谱。所以军队仍然保留着老德皇时期的黑、白、红三色旗。
It doesn't have the colors that we associate with Germany today, which are the Weimar colors, which are black, red, and gold. The army is still very monarchist. The army is ignoring the Versailles Treaty. There are a lot of people in the army who basically can't wait to get rid of this new Weimar Republic. They think it's completely illegitimate. And what about the civil service? Same thing. Because of course, a lot of civil servants are former military people. So if you were in the army under the Kaiser, you got preference for state jobs. So even postmen, you know, state-employed, I don't know, janitors or whatever, they're often former military men. So all these people, you know, the people, the bureaucrats who are basically carrying out the Weimar Republic's instructions. A lot of them think this is a load of dodgy lefty traitors who sold us down the river, and the whole thing is illegitimate, and I can't wait for it to go away.
它没有使用我们今天与德国联系在一起的颜色——也就是魏玛的黑、红、金三色旗。军队依然非常保皇。军队无视《凡尔赛条约》。军队里有许多人基本上恨不得马上除掉这个新的魏玛共和国。他们认为这完全是非法的。那公务员呢？情况一样。因为理所当然地，许多公务员都是前军人。所以，如果你在威廉二世统治下的军队服役过，你在国家工作时就会享有优先权。所以即使是邮递员，你知道的，国家雇用的清洁工什么的，他们往往都是前军人。所以所有人，你知道的，那些基本上在执行魏玛共和国指令的人、官僚们。他们当中有许多人认为这是一群不可靠的左翼叛徒，把我们给出卖了，整个体制都是非法的，我恨不得它立刻消失。
So the Weimar has lots of governments rising and falling because it has endless coalitions. I think it has 20 different cabinets between 1919 and 1933. So there's constant coalition building. But some of the biggest parties in Germany never accept the Weimar Republic. An obvious example is the communists. So the communists in the mid-1920s are getting three to four million votes. They're absolutely explicit about it. They think it's a bourgeois capitalist construct.
因此，魏玛经历了无数届政府的上台和倒台，因为它有着无休止的联合政府。我想在1919年至1933年间，它有20个不同的内阁。所以总是在组建联合政府。但是德国一些最大的政党却从来不接受魏玛共和国。一个明显的例子就是共产党。因此，在20世纪20年代中期，共产党获得了三到四百万张选票。他们对此绝对直言不讳。他们认为这是一个资产阶级资本主义的产物。
Yeah, a racket, exactly. Running dogs of capitalism. Can't wait to sweep it away. But, rackets, exactly. Running dogs of capitalism. Can't wait to sweep it away. But the nationalists, so that's the biggest sort of right-wing group, bigger than any other group except for the Social Democrats,
是的，就是一个骗局，完全如此。资本主义的走狗。恨不得马上把它扫进历史的垃圾堆。但是，骗局，完全如此。资本主义的走狗。恨不得马上把它扫进历史的垃圾堆。但是民族主义者——
they, again, are absolutely explicit. They say, bring back the Second Reich, bring back the Kaiser. They wave the old flags. The biggest cheese in nationalist politics, who was a press parent called alfred hugenberg he's drunk very deeply of all this stuff in the 1880s and 1890s pan-germanism
也就是右翼中最大的群体，比除了社会民主党以外的任何其他群体都大——他们同样直言不讳。他们说，恢复第二帝国，恢复德皇。他们挥舞着旧国旗。民族主义政坛最大的巨头——一个名叫阿尔弗雷德·胡根贝格的报业大亨，他在1880和1890年代深受泛日耳曼主义、
social darwinism nietzsche laban's realm anti-semitism he's very very extreme he's always shouting about judom all of this business so in other words from the start so left and right there are loads of people who want weimar to fail and i think most historians would say even with a fair wind this was a pretty fragile construction with an awful lot of people who ought to have been able to rely on, who regard it as an affront, as tainted, and they want it to fall apart. And of course, as we'll see, it never does get a fair wind. There is actually another element I thought which would interest you, Tom, because you're interested in ideas and ideology, which is the ideas and the sort of ideological and cultural swirl of the 1920s, I think, plays a part in discrediting Weimar.
社会达尔文主义、尼采、生存空间论、反犹太主义等思想的毒害。他非常非常极端，总是叫嚷着“犹太人”以及诸如此类的事情。换句话说，从一开始——无论是左翼还是右翼，都有大量的人希望魏玛失败。我想大多数历史学家都会说，即使有一帆风顺的环境，这也是一个相当脆弱的架构，有那么多本应可以依靠的人却把它视为一种侮辱、带有污点，并且希望它土崩解瓦。当然，正如我们将会看到的，它从来没有过一帆风顺的环境。事实上，还有另一个元素我想你会感兴趣，汤姆，因为你对思想和意识形态很感兴趣，那就是20世纪20年代的思想、意识形态和文化风潮，我认为它在抹黑魏玛方面起了一定作用。
Because this is an age, I mean, we talk about culture wars. I mean, it seems ludicrous to talk about culture wars in 21st century Britain. When you think about the kind of culture wars in the 20s Germany, everything from expressionist films and nightclubs and jazz. Yeah. So it's cabaret, isn't it? I mean, for English speakers, that's the image of it. Or have you ever seen, there's a TV series called Babylon Berlin? Yeah.
因为这是一个时代——我的意思是，我们谈论文化战争。在21世纪的英国谈论文化战争似乎荒谬绝伦。当你想到20年代德国的那种文化战争时，从表现主义电影、夜总会到爵士乐，无所不包。是的。所以那是卡巴莱歌舞表演，对吧？我的意思是，对于英语国家的人来说，这就是它的形象。或者你看过一部名为《巴比伦柏林》的电视剧吗？是的。
Big fan. I've mentioned this before on the podcast. Absolutely brilliant. So it's all that sort of image that you have of kind of- Decadence. Cross-dressing decadence in Berlin nightclubs, in cellars, people listening to jazz and swing and all getting off with each other and drinking cocktails and talking to Bertolt Brecht.
超级粉丝。我以前在播客里提到过这个。绝对精彩。所以这就是你脑海中那种——颓废的印象。柏林夜总会里那种易装癖的颓废，在地下室里，人们听着爵士乐和摇摆乐，互相鬼混，喝着鸡尾酒，跟贝托尔特·布莱希特聊天。
Although apparently the favourite drink among Weimar politicians, it wasn't cocktails, it was liquid yoghurt. I read it in Michael Burley's's book so it must be i didn't realize he was so strong on yogurt yeah apparently this this was the the taste of feimar but the other the other thing that is happening though is incredible street violence yeah and that presumably is an inheritance from, the kind of the militarized society that Germany was during the First World War, but also this kind of, you know, the way that you have street battles raging in Berlin, in Munich, across most of the German cities. And the way in which it's not just the communists and the far right parties have kind of paramilitary wings. I mean, even the major, you know, the social Democrats do. Yeah, everybody has a paramilitary wing. Absolutely.
尽管显然魏玛政治家最喜欢的饮料不是鸡尾酒，而是液体酸奶。我是从迈克尔·伯利的书中读到的，所以一定千真万确。我没意识到他在酸奶方面这么狂热。对的，显然这就是魏玛的风味。不过，正在发生的另一件事是难以置信的街头暴力。是的，这大概是继承自德国在第一次世界大战期间那种军事化社会，同时也源于柏林、慕尼黑以及大多数德国城市中横行的街头激战。而且不仅仅是共产党和极右翼政党拥有准军事组织。我的意思是，甚至连主要的、你知道的，社会民主党也有。是的，每个党都有准军事组织。绝对是这样。
So they've all, we talked a tiny bit in the first episode about the army came back, brutalized, I suppose you would say, inured to violence after the trenches. Of course, the war doesn't, the fighting doesn't actually end for all the Germans in November 1918. So there are still German units fighting in the utter chaos of the East, in the Baltic and so on, where everything has completely fallen apart. All borders have been erased and it's sort of everything's up for grabs. So this is the Freikorps, these sort of, they're kind of freebooter units. They're wearing German army uniforms, but they're kind of going off and
所以他们全都——我们在第一集里简单聊过，军队回来了，变得很残暴，你可以这么说，在战壕里历练后对暴力习以为常。当然，并不是所有德国人在1918年11月战斗就真的结束了。所以仍然有德国部队在东方的一片混乱中、在波罗的海等地继续战斗，那里的一切都已经彻底土崩瓦解。所有边界都被抹去了，一切都处于争夺之中。这就是自由军团，这些某种程度上像是一支支自由掠夺部队。他们穿着德国陆军制服，但他们是在自行其是、
doing their own thing. They all come back in the 1920s and there are hundreds of thousands of men who actually enjoyed fighting, who liked the camaraderie, the sense of belonging. Well, that's what the far right is all about, isn't it? It's the idea that men should get out there and fight. And that's what Darwinism tells you. That's what nature is. So I suppose you could you could trace trace it back couldn't you to the sort of social darwinism the emphasis on struggle i think that plays a part obviously the experience of the first world war plays a massive part and and those two things flow together with the experiences of all these young men into this
我行我素。他们在20世纪20年代全部回到了国内，有成百上千的男人其实很享受战斗，喜欢那种袍泽之情、归属感。好吧，这正是极右翼的全部意义所在，不是吗？这就是那种认为男人应该走出去战斗的想法。达尔文主义就是这么告诉你的。这就是大自然。所以我想你可以把这追溯到社会达尔文主义，对斗争的强调。我认为这发挥了一定的作用，显然第一次世界大战的经历发挥了巨大的作用，这两者与所有这些年轻人的经历交融在一起，汇入了20世纪20年代这种——除了战争，没有别的词可以形容的——文化氛围中。
sort of culture in the 1920s of war there's no other way of putting it. Everybody, lots of people wearing uniforms, constant talk of smashing, crushing, you know, all of that sort of stuff, that rhetoric. But also the fact that on the left as well, you have the prospect of violent revolution is absolutely seen as a good. So on both sides of the extremes of both, there is an appetite for violence, not as something, you know, regrettable necessity, but as something absolutely to be celebrated and stoked.
每个人、许多人穿着制服，不断谈论着粉碎、碾压，你知道的，诸如此类的事情，那种激昂的修辞。但同时，在左翼也是如此，暴力革命的前景被绝对视为一件好事。因此在双方的极端势力中，都对暴力有着渴望，暴力不被视为某种令人遗憾的必要恶，而是被当作一件绝对值得庆祝和煽动的事。
Yeah, I suppose the paramilitary leagues are the kind of institutionalization of that. And as you said, each party has one. So there's a veterans group called the Steel Helmets. This is massive. I mean, hundreds of thousands of members. They join the Steel Helmets. And the Steel Helmets are the kind of the helmets that the Germans wore in the First World War. Yeah, the First World War. So they're the helmets we associate with World War II, but they are wearing them at the end of the First World War. The steel helmets are, I suppose, vaguely nominally neutral, but they're not. They end up being drawn to the far right. The nationalists have their fighting leagues. The communists have what's called the Red Front Fighting League.
是的，我想准军事同盟就是这种现象的制度化表现。正如你所说，每个政党都有一个。所以有一个名为“钢盔前线士兵联盟”的退伍军人组织。这个规模极其庞大。我的意思是，有成百上千的成员。他们加入了钢盔前线士兵联盟。钢盔前线士兵联盟戴的就是那种德国人在第一次世界大战中戴的头盔。对，第一次世界大战。所以那是我们与第二次世界大战联系在一起的头盔，但他们在第一次世界大战结束时就已经戴着它们了。钢盔前线联盟，我想在名义上大概是中立的，但其实不然。他们最终被吸引到了极右翼。民族主义者有他们的战斗同盟。共产党有被称为“红军战士同盟”的组织。
The Nazis, of course, have the stormtroopers, so they're wearing their brown shirts, the Sturmabteilung. I mean, initially they were called something like the gymnastics and sports section because that was an attempt to get around the law. But, you know, as you said, the Social Democrats. So this is the party of Weimar, the party that was the biggest party in Germany, that has created this new republic, that is kind of the left-wing party, the Labour Party, if you like. They have their own paramilitary group, the Reichsbanner
纳粹党当然有冲锋队，所以他们穿着棕色衬衫，即冲锋队（Sturmabteilung）。我的意思是，最初他们被叫做体操和体育科之类名字，因为那是为了企图钻法律的空子。但是，正如你所说，社会民主党——所以这是魏玛的政党，在德国规模最大的政党，创建了这个新共和国的政党，可以说是左翼政党、工党（如果你愿意这么称呼的话）。他们拥有自己的准军事组织——帝国旗
Schwarz-Rot-Gold. So paramilitary politics is part of Weimar from the very beginning. So that's not good, is it? No. That's not contributing to the stability of the system. And then you have the economy. Yes. So if you'd had all that, could you still have survived? Maybe.
黑红金团。因此，准军事政治从一开始就是魏玛的一部分。所以这可不是什么好事，对吧？不。这并没有为体制的稳定做出贡献。然后你还有经济问题。是的。如果经历了所有这些，还能存活下来吗？也许吧。
I mean, maybe. Because it's the economy, stupid. If people are rich and stable, they don't have a stake in pulling things down, do they? Right. Yeah. The less people care about politics, the better. 1920s Germany is a very, very intensely politicized society. When people are moaning about apathy in politics, I always think, you know, be careful what you
我的意思是，也许能。因为关键在于经济，笨蛋。如果人们富有且稳定，他们就没有动力去把一切推翻，对吧？对的，是的。人们越是不关心政治，情况就越好。20世纪20年代的德国是一个政治化程度极高、极其严重的社会。每当人们抱怨政治冷漠时，我总是想，你知道，小心你许下的愿望，因为在魏玛德国，人们绝对谈不上冷漠。当然，他们不冷漠的一个原因是因为他们的生活水平正在被摧毁。正如你在第一期播客中所说，德国人为了支付第一次世界大战的费用借了大量的钱。所以物价在1914年到——期间翻了一番。
wish for, because they definitely weren't apathetic in Weimar Germany. And of course, one reason they're not apathetic is because their living standards are being destroyed. So as you said in the first podcast, the Germans had been borrowing a lot of money to pay for World War I. So prices had doubled between 1914- And the plan was that they would recoup this from reparations from their enemies when they won. Yeah. Unfortunately, they don't win. So inflation is now absolutely through the roof. They have borrowed and printed so much money that they haven't basically earned to pay for the war.
而且当时的计划是，等他们获胜后，可以从敌人的战争赔款中收回这笔钱。是的。不幸的是，他们并没有赢。所以现在通货膨胀彻底失控了。他们借了并印刷了如此多的钱，而这些钱根本不是他们赚来支付战争费用的。
And now they're having to borrow it and to print it to pay for the reparations. Because, of course, no sane government wants to raise taxes on Germans to give to the French and the British. Because then you really are, you do look like a terrible traitor and November criminal and stuff. So to give you a sense of, I mean, inflation, it can sound so abstract. Of course, these days, to a lot of people listening to this podcast,
现在他们不得不继续借钱和印钱来支付赔款。因为，当然，没有哪个神智清醒的政府会向德国人加税，好把钱给法国人和英国人。因为那样的话，你看起来真的就像个十恶不赦的叛徒和十一月罪犯之类的人。为了让你对——我的意思是，通货膨胀听起来可能非常抽象。当然，如今对于收听这个播客的许多人来说，
it won't seem abstract without we're living with inflation at 10%. But in August 1922, to buy one US dollar, it took you 1,000 marks. By December 1922, it took you 7,000 marks. Then something terrible happens to Germany. Because they're slow in repaying their reparations, the French, because they haven't been handing over all the coal they should have done, occupy the main industrial region of Germany, the Ruhr. They send in troops. Some of them are black colonial troops, aren't they? Right.
如果我们要忍受10%的通货膨胀，这听起来就不会那么抽象了。但在1922年8月，购买一个美元需要1000马克。到1922年12月，需要7000马克。然后，德国发生了一件可怕的事。因为他们支付赔款的速度很慢，法国人——由于德国人没有按规定交出所有的煤炭——占领了德国的主要工业区鲁尔。他们派出了军队。其中一些是黑人殖民地军队，对吧？没错。
Some of them are Senegalese and whatnot, African troops. So that doesn't go down well with the far right. No, the Germans are extremely, extremely displeased with this. This is a great boost, actually, for the Nazi party and for other far right nationalist parties. But the French intervention in the Ruhr coincides with basically the total implosion of the German economy and inflation becoming hyperinflation.
其中一些是塞内加尔人和其他非洲部队。所以极右翼对此非常反感。不，德国人对此极其、极其不满。这实际上对纳粹党和其他极右翼民族主义政党是一个巨大的推动。但法国对鲁尔的军事干预，恰逢德国经济彻底崩溃以及通货膨胀演变成恶性通货膨胀。
And it's actually so vast, it's impossible to comprehend. So I said a dollar had been 1,000 marks in August 1922. By July 1923, to buy $1, it takes you 353,000 marks. And just to go through the numbers, it's laughable. August, it's a million and a half marks. To buy $1 in September 1923, 98 million marks. October, I think that's 25 billion, is it, Tom? The numbers are... Lots of noughts. So many noughts, you can't count them up. Well, let's count. So 42, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11 noughts. Yeah. So this is all the famous stuff that everyone knows about. Big wheelbarrows full of money. In Richard Evans' book, he says, basically, you would go into a cafe and you'd order a cup of coffee for 5,000 marks. And if you stay there for an hour
而且它实在是太庞大了，根本无法理解。所以我刚才说，在1922年8月，一美元是1000马克。到1923年7月，购买一美元需要353,000马克。我们简单看一下这些数字，简直荒谬。到了8月，是一百五十万马克。到1923年9月，购买一美元需要9800万马克。10月份，我想那是250亿，对吧，汤姆？这些数字……有太多的零。零多得你根本数不过来。好吧，我们来数数。所以是42后面跟了——1、2、3、4、5、6、7、8、9、10、11个零。是的。所以这就是所有人都知道的那些出名的事情。装着满满一车现金的手推车。理查德·埃文斯的书里说，基本上，你走进一家咖啡馆，点了一杯5000马克的咖啡。如果你在那里待了一个小时，
for too long, you might ask for the bill and it's gone up to 8,000 marks in the intervening period. And the other is the price of bread. So to buy some bread at the beginning of the year would cost you 163 marks. But by the end of the year, it costs you 233 billion marks. And so as people will know from the much less severe manifestations of inflation at the moment, this tends to pauperize people. If you've got savings. It eliminates them. But it's also kind of like hemlock rising up the body. So the working classes get pauperized and then the middle classes start to get pauperized Michael Burley, he makes this brilliant point that this is a society where your occupation and your title
待的时间太久，你可能要求结账时，在此期间账单已经涨到了8000马克。另一个就是面包的价格。年初买一些面包只需花费163马克。但到了年底，花费高达2330亿马克。因此，正如人们从目前不那么严重的通货膨胀表现中所知道的那样，这往往会使人变得赤贫。如果你有存款的话。它会把存款清零。但这也有点像毒芹在身体里蔓延。所以工人阶级先陷入赤贫，接着中产阶级也开始陷入赤贫。迈克尔·伯利提出了一个绝妙的观点，这是一个在电话簿里会把你的职业和头衔都列出来的社会。
are listed in the telephone directory. So it is a very status-obsessed society. So when you have to start enduring humiliations of someone who's not used to them, that's going to radicalize you. Oh, absolutely. I always think, Tom, we were talking before about what it would have been like to be a German before the First World War.
所以这是一个对地位极其痴迷的社会。因此，当你不得不开始忍受一个不习惯这种屈辱的人所遭受的屈辱时，这将会使你激进化。哦，绝对会。我总是觉得，汤姆，我们之前在谈论第一次世界大战前的德国人会是什么样子。
I always think about Thomas Mann, the writer. I mean, the sort of people he writes about in his great book, Buddenbrooks, which is set a bit earlier, set in Lubeck. These sort of incredibly respectable… Solid. Solid. Yeah. Good burglary. Yeah, exactly.
我总是想起作家托马斯·曼。我的意思是，他在他的巨著《布登勃洛克一家》中描写的那类人，故事背景发生得稍早一些，设定在吕贝克。那些极其受人尊敬的……坚实。坚实。是的。好极了，伯利。对，没错。
These people who are incredibly serious, sober, sort of Protestant virtues, they take their respectability so seriously. Imagine you've had a brother or a son or a father killed in the trenches in the Great War, in a war that you thought was just. You've lost the war. The Kaiser is gone. Everything you believed in. Now you're losing your savings. You've got a family member who, as you said, you know, has turned to dodgy methods to make ends meet.
这些人极其严肃、稳重，有着某种新教美德，他们对自己的尊贵地位看得无比重要。想象一下，你在大战的战壕里失去了一个兄弟、一个儿子或一个父亲，死于一场你认为正义的战争。你输掉了战争。德皇退位了。你所信仰的一切都破灭了。现在你正在失去你的存款。你有一个家庭成员，正如你所说，你知道的，为了维持生计已经开始求助于不正当的手段。
You're terrified about crime. And this is a society obsessed with crime. All those great German expressionist films of the 1920s. Dr. Caligari and all that. Dr. Caligari, M, serial killers, speculators, fraudsters, all of those kinds of things. There is, I mean, we talked in the first episode about the obsession with medicalization,
你对犯罪感到恐惧。这是一个对犯罪着迷的社会。20世纪20年代所有那些伟大的德国表现主义电影。卡里加里博士之类的。卡里加里博士、电影《M就是凶手》、连环杀手、投机商、骗子，所有这些类型。我的意思是，我们在第一集里谈到过对医学化、
with pests, with plagues, with germs. with germs rats so that's on your mind the whole time and so you are asking who's to blame where are these you know where has where has this disease this plague come from who's responsible for it yeah so the anti-semitism that we talked about in episode one so it was on the fringinges then. It had seeped into some aspects of mainstream politics, you know, the Kaiser and the Chancellor Bethman-Holweg, where they had read anti-Semitic tracts. But anti-Semitism is not yet this sort of commanding motif of political life, but definitely by the mid-1920s. The idea of the November traitors, a Jewish conspiracy, Jewish speculators. So the Jews are simultaneously in this world, Bolshevik subversives and rich financial speculators.
对害虫、瘟疫、病菌的痴迷。对病菌、老鼠的痴迷，所以这些时刻盘旋在你的脑海中。因此你一直在问，到底是谁的错？这些——你知道的，这个疾病、这场瘟疫是从哪里来的？谁应该对此负责？是的，所以我们在第一集里谈到的反犹太主义，在当时还处于边缘状态。它已经渗入了主流政治的一些方面，你知道的，德皇和首相贝特曼-霍尔韦格都曾阅读过反犹太主义的小册子。但反犹太主义当时还不是政治生活中那种统领全局的主题，不过到了20世纪20年代中期，情况绝对变了。关于十一月叛徒、犹太人阴谋、犹太投机商的想法。因此在这个世界里，犹太人同时既是布尔什维克颠覆分子，又是富有的金融投机商。
And again, you can see elements of that in other cultures, can't you? I always think about those very first Agatha Christie books from the 1920s. John Buchan or Bulldog Drummond, that kind of weird paranoia. But I mean, also just to repeat though, it's not just the Jews who are being blamed. It's the whole political establishment. And again, I suppose there's a kind of echo of that in the way that people today don't necessarily blame one or either of the parties for it. They blame Westminster. They blame the whole crew of politicians. They're all frauds. Americans blaming Washington.
同样，你可以在其他文化中看到这种元素的影子，不是吗？我总是想起20世纪20年代阿加莎·克里斯蒂的那些早期作品。约翰·巴肯或《德拉姆德斗牛犬》，那种奇怪的偏执狂。不过，我的意思是，也要再次重申，受到责备的不仅仅是犹太人。整个政治建制派都在被责备。而且，我觉得这其中又有一种回响，就像今天的人们不一定会把责任归咎于其中一个或两个政党一样。他们责备威斯敏斯特。他们责备整群政客。他们全都是骗子。美国人则在责备华盛顿。
Yes, Washington. I think that instinct is always there in any democracy, no matter how healthy. And in fact, you could argue, it can be quite a healthy sign, the kind of the country distrust of the Whigs in the 18th century. You know, their corrupt cabal with their fricassees and their ragus, Tom, as you remember from the podcast we did about Beef and Liberty. You know, there's always a distrust of the centre and of the political elite. With their yoghurts. Their yoghurt drinks, exactly. But of course, in 1920s Weimar Germany, it is turbocharged beyond anything that anybody had ever seen in Britain.
是的，华盛顿。我认为这种本能无论在多么健康的民主体制中都是始终存在的。事实上，你可以争辩说，这可能是一种相当健康的迹象，比如18世纪对辉格党的普遍不信任。你知道，正如你在我们制作的关于“牛肉与自由”的播客中所记得的那样，他们与肉汤和杂烩汤狼狈为奸、腐败的政治集团，汤姆。你知道，人们对权力中心和政治精英总是存在一种不信任。伴随着他们的酸奶。他们的酸奶饮品，完全正确。但是，当然，在20世纪20年代的魏玛德国，这种情绪被放大了，超越了英国人所见过的任何事物。
So the inflation actually does come to an end. One of the other great politicians of the Weimar Republic, say Friedrich Ebert, is one, a chap called Gustav Stresemann. He's not a social democrat. He's a liberal. He takes over in August 1993. He introduces a new currency called the rent and mark to stabilize things. He also says, listen, we can't have this situation, the shambles where we're not paying our reparations to the allies. And so they are just punishing us and making life impossible. He basically does a deal. He says he will get the French, he gets the French to withdraw from the Ruhr,
因此，通货膨胀实际上确实迎来了终结。魏玛共和国的另一位伟人——弗里德里希·艾伯特算一个，另一位则是古斯塔夫·施特雷泽曼。他不是社会民主党人。他是一名自由派。他在1923年8月上台。他引入了一种名为“地租马克”的新货币来稳定局势。他还说，听着，我们不能再这样下去了，我们不向盟国支付赔偿金的这种混乱局面，只会让他们不断惩罚我们，让我们的生活无法继续。他基本上达成了一项交易。他说他会促使法国人，他让法国人从鲁尔撤军，
and in return, Germany will fulfill its obligations. But he says, we all agree these are completely unfair. If we show the Allies in good faith that we will make the payment, that will give us the kind of political capital, if you like, to renegotiate. And actually, it works, because the allies do amend the terms in something called the Dawes Plan. But it's a sophisticated argument, isn't it, in an age when people aren't necessarily up for taking on board
作为交换，德国将履行其义务。但他表示：我们都一致认为这些完全是不公平的。如果我们向盟国表现出我们将会付款的诚意，这将为我们赢得某种政治资本（如果你愿意这么称呼的话），从而重新谈判。实际上，这确实奏效了，因为盟国确实在被称为“道斯计划”的方案中修改了条款。但这是一种复杂的论点，对吧，在一个人们未必乐于接受复杂论点的时代？
sophisticated arguments? Well, imagine you think you've been wronged and somebody says, listen, the way to deal with this is to continue paying the people you think have wronged you and eventually they'll be kind to you. I mean, you're maybe not going to listen to that. Now, I think Streisand obviously was completely right to do what he did. But if you're a right-wing German nationalist,
好吧，想象一下，如果你认为自己受到了冤枉，而有人对你说：听着，处理这件事的方法就是继续向你认为冤枉了你的人付款，最终他们会对你好的。我的意思是，你可能不会去听这种话。现在，我认为施特雷泽曼这样做显然完全是正确的。但如果你是一个右翼德国民族主义者，
you are outraged. Specifically, if you're a Mr. A. Hitler, you're not going to buy it, are you? So Hitler's been in Munich all this time. His party is getting bigger, and he is getting more and more impatient. So let's have a break. And when we come back, let's look at how that impatience is manifesting itself.
你就会感到无比愤怒。尤其是，如果你是一个名叫A·希特勒的先生，你肯定不会买账，对吧？所以希特勒这段时间一直待在慕尼黑。他的政党越来越大，他也变得越来越没有耐心。让我们休息一下。当我们回来时，让我们看看这种急躁情绪是如何表现出来的。
What happens? We'll see you in a few minutes. Bye-bye. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our on our q a we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad-free listening bonus episodes and early
究竟发生了什么？我们几分钟后见。拜拜。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐其余部分》。这是你获取娱乐新闻、评论以及八卦爆料的每周必听节目。在我们问答环节中，我们将拉开娱乐行业的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部，如果你想享受无广告音频、加更节目以及抢先购买现场演出门票，请前往 restistentertainment.com，那是——《历史其余部分》第二集第二部分，关于纳粹崛起史的叙述。不过多米尼克，我们正处于——比方说1923年的夏末。你一直在为魏玛德国的更广阔背景搭建舞台。但对于纳粹而言，我们其实仍然主要在慕尼黑，对吧？我的意思是，他们并没有真正传播到那个范围之外。甚至在慕尼黑的背景下，他们也只是一个派系。那么他们有多大？希特勒在其他纳粹分子面前的地位如何？
access to live tickets head to the rest of the entertainment.com that's the rest is history a part two of episode two of our uh account of the rise of the nazis but dominic we're in let's say late summer 1923 uh you've been setting the scene in the broader context of Weimar Germany. But with the Nazis, we're still very much in Munich, right? I mean, they haven't really kind of spread beyond that. And even in the context of Munich, they're a faction. So how large are they? What's Hitler's position vis-a-vis the other Nazis?
他们到底在搞什么名堂？所以纳粹现在基本上是希特勒的党了。自1921年以来，希特勒一直是纳粹信息的化身。他是党的领袖。因为这就是关键所在，对吧？他并不是凭自己就能代表政治家的。他是化身。他是，但他依然只是个鼓手。记住，我们在上一期播客的结尾谈到过，希特勒把自己视为敲鼓的人，视为施洗约翰。总有一天会有一场国民革命，德国将再度伟大。他之所以这么想，是因为前一年贝尼托·墨索里尼领导了向罗马进军。因此希特勒有了国家领袖应该是什么样子的榜样。
What's going on with them? So the Nazis now are very much Hitler's party. Since 1921, Hitler's been the embodiment of the Nazi message. He is the leader of the party. Because that's the thing, isn't it? He's not a representative politician in his own lights. He's the embodiment. He is, but he's still only the drummer. Remember, we ended the last podcast by talking about how Hitler sees himself as the drummer, as John the Baptist. One day there will be a national revolution and Germany will be great again. And is he thinking this because the year before, Benito Mussolini has led the march on Rome. And so Hitler has the example of what a national leader could be.
这对他有很大的影响吗？我认为影响巨大。墨索里尼对希特勒产生了巨大的影响。所以希特勒——阅读希特勒的传记，我会说这很有可能是真的。我的意思是，我们怎么能知道希特勒脑子里在想什么呢？但在1922年10月发生的向罗马进军，很可能开始改变了希特勒对自身可能做成之事的认知。
Is that a big influence on him? I think it's massive. Mussolini is an enormous influence on Hitler. So Hitler, it's probable, I would say, reading the biographies of Hitler, I mean, we can't, how can we tell what's going on in Hitler's head? But it is probable that the March on Rome in October 1922 begins to change Hitler's sense of what is possible for him to do.
所以实际上，如果你是一个好赌的人，在1922年，你会说极右翼最可能的旗手将是埃里希·鲁登道夫将军。也就是在第一次世界大战结束时统治德国的两个人之一，他曾短暂流亡，后来又回来了。他是“背后捅刀子”和“十一月罪犯”谎言的策划者。他后来转向了极右翼，并最终来到了慕尼黑。所以鲁登道夫这位战时领袖，看起来是一个显而易见的人选。
So actually, if you were a betting man, in 1922, you would have said the most likely standard bearer for the far right will be General Ludendorff. So one of the two men who had run Germany at the end of the First World War, he's briefly gone into exile. He'd come back. He's the architect of the stab in the back, November criminals kind of lie. And he has since moved to the far right, and he's ended up in Munich. So Ludendorff is this sort of wartime leader. He seems the obvious person.
但正如你所说，墨索里尼曾经是一名记者。他曾经是个无名小卒，真的。有点像希特勒。同样也带有左翼背景。曾从左翼走向右翼。意大利法西斯主义和纳粹主义有许多相似之处。强调暴力、对议会制的怀疑、受害者心态、敬礼、民族主义。
But as you say, Mussolini is a former journalist. He's a former nobody, really. A bit like Hitler. Also kind of from the left. Has come from the left and moved to the right. Fascism, Italian fascism and Nazism have lots of similarities. Emphasis on violence, distrust of parliamentarianism, sense of victimhood, salutes, nationalism.
但正如你所说，墨索里尼曾是一名记者。实际上，他曾经是个无名小卒。有点像希特勒。也算是出身左翼。从左翼转向了右翼。法西斯主义、意大利法西斯主义和纳粹主义有很多相似之处。强调暴力、不信任议会制、受害者情结、举手礼、民族主义。
Well, I mean, the Nazis are copying, deliberately copying the salutes, the goose stepping all these kinds of things from the italians uh the eagles the standards also the idea of seizing power um so mussolini i mean the march on rome in october 1922 is much mythologized but at the end of it mussolini is the duce the. And so the idea of a march on Berlin? I mean, that kind of idea is floating around far right circles as you get into 1923. So in October 1923, Hitler actually gives an interview with, of all papers, he gives an interview to the Daily Mail in which he says, if a German Mussolini were given to Germany,
我的意思是，纳粹党在刻意模仿意大利人的敬礼、鹅步等等，还有鹰徽、军旗，以及夺权的理念——墨索里尼，1922年10月的进军罗马虽然被神话了，但在那之后，墨索里尼成了最高领袖（Duce）。因此，进军柏林的想法？这种想法在1923年进入极右翼圈子时开始流传。所以，在1923年10月，希特勒居然接受了采访，偏偏是接受了《每日邮报》的采访，他在采访中表示，如果德国能有一个德国的墨索里尼，
the people would kneel down and worship him more than Mussolini has ever been worshipped. At this stage, does Hitler think of himself as the German Mussolini? It's not clear. The idea must be taking shape in his mind. I don't think you'd say that without at least the kind of glimmering of a kind of hunch that it might be. Agreed. So the road to his attempted seizure of power, such a strange and complicated story. Munich is basically being run by a triumvirate, a right-wing triumvirate. There's a guy called Gustav Ritter von Kahr
人民会跪下崇拜他，程度甚至超过墨索里尼以往受到的崇拜。在这个阶段，希特勒把自己看作德国的墨索里尼吗？这并不清楚。这个想法当时一定正在他脑海中成形。我觉得如果没有哪怕一点点预感或者直觉认为这可能会发生，他是不会说出那种话的。确实。所以他试图夺权的道路，是一个如此离奇且复杂的历史故事。慕尼黑当时基本上是由一个三人执政团统治，一个右翼的三人执政团。其中有个家伙叫古斯塔夫·里特尔·冯·卡尔，
who runs the government. Colonel von Saiser runs the police. General von Lossow runs the army. And they're running Munich. And they, it seems, by the end of 1923 or the second half of 1923, they have their own plan to topple the Weimar Republic and General Ludendorff on the other. And each of these three parties, I think, thinks they're using the others and that they're the people who will basically- Well, this will be a running theme of Nazi history.
他负责掌管政府。冯·赛瑟上校负责管理警察。洛索夫将军负责管理军队。他们掌管着慕尼黑。而且在1923年底或1923年下半年，他们似乎有了自己的计划，打算推翻魏玛共和国，而鲁登道夫将军则站在另一边。这三方中的每一方，我想，都以为自己在利用其他人，并且觉得自己才是那个基本上——好吧，这将成为纳粹历史上一贯的主题。
Everybody thinks they're using everybody else. Exactly. The terrible mistake that people keep making with the Nazis. They talk to the army in Berlin and the head of the army in Berlin says, no, I'm not really up for this. So at that point, the guys in Munich, the Munich authority people, they say, well, you know, we're not going to do this either then. You know, no point. Hitler is sort of conscious that he stoked everything up for the last year or so. And there's always outrage about the hyperinflation
每个人都以为自己在利用其他人。没错。人们在面对纳粹时不断犯下的可怕错误。他们与柏林的军方交谈，柏林军方的负责人说，不，我对此实在不感兴趣。所以在那一刻，慕尼黑的那些家伙，慕尼黑当局的人，他们就说，好吧，你知道的，那我们也不干了。你知道，毫无意义。希特勒多少意识到过去这一年左右他把一切都煽动起来了。人们总是对恶性通货膨胀感到愤怒，
and about the French and the Ruhr and reparations. That if he doesn't act, if he doesn't make the great gesture, then his support people will say, well, he's all talk. Yeah. You know, no action. And so he and Ludendorff decide what will force the issue. They know that on the 9th of November, which is the fifth anniversary of the outbreak of the German revolution in 1918,
还有对法国人占领鲁尔区以及战争赔款的愤怒。如果他不采取行动，如果他不做出那个宏大的姿态，那么支持他的人就会说，好吧，他只会空谈。是的。你知道，毫无行动。于是他和鲁登道夫决定做点什么来迫使局势摊牌。他们知道在11月9日这一天，也就是1918年德国革命爆发五周年的日子，
they know that Carr, the boss of the German revolution in 1918, they know that Kahr, the boss of the Munich government, basically, he's going to be addressing a meeting in the Bürgerbräukeller in Munich, which is this sort of citizens brewery cellar. And he'll be shouting about November traders and all this sort of stuff, which he is doing. Kara's doing that, the triumvirate are there. That evening, Hitler bursts in with a load of guys in brown shirts. It's just this stormtrooper. It's his kind of paramilitary wing, little paramilitary wing, and General Ludendorff.
他们知道，1918年德国革命的头目卡尔——哦不，他们知道卡尔，慕尼黑政府的掌权者，基本上，他要在慕尼黑的贝格勃劳凯勒啤酒馆发表讲话，这是一个类似于市民酿酒厂地窖的地方。他会在那里大喊大叫关于十一月罪人之类的事情，而他当时也确实在这么做。卡尔在这么干，三人执政团也在那里。那天晚上，希特勒带着一大帮穿着褐衫的人突然闯了进去。这只是一群冲锋队。这是他的准军事翼，他自己的小准军事翼，还有鲁登道夫将军。
It's complete chaos in the room. Hitler takes out his revolver, which is a Browning, and he shoots a bullet into the ceiling. He says, the building is surrounded. My brown shirts are here. This is the moment. He takes the triumvirate away, and he says to them, listen, I'm forcing the issue.
屋子里一片混乱。希特勒掏出他的左轮手枪，那是一把勃朗宁手枪，朝天花板开了一枪。他说，大楼已经被包围了。我的褐衫军就在这里。就是现在。他把三人执政团带走，对他们说，听着，我在逼迫你们表态。
We're marching on Berlin. I'll be the head of the cabinet, the head of government. Ludendorff will be the head of the army, and von Kahr, the guy who's been running Bavaria, you can be the head of state as a regent for the Kaiser. You see, there's still a lot of monarchism around, actually. It's very interesting how long that lingers. They all say, fine, all right, whatever.
我们要向柏林进军。我将担任内阁首脑、政府首脑，鲁登道夫将担任军队首脑，而冯·卡尔，你这个一直统治巴伐利亚的家伙，你可以作为德皇的摄政王担任国家元首。你看，当时实际上还有很多君主主义思想。这种思想残留了这么久，真的非常有趣。他们都说，行，好吧，随便吧。
They go back in, talk to the crowd. Hitler gives a great speech, shouts about the Berlin Jew government, says, you know, this is the end of it. This very sort of, stirring is not the right word for that, I'll fit it there. Well, but in a sense it is, isn't it? I mean, he does stir people up. He does rouse people. He does make people feel that, you know, he makes their blood race faster.
他们走回人群中。希特勒发表了一场精彩的演讲，痛骂柏林犹太人政府，说，你知道的，这一切都结束了。这种非常——“煽动”这个词用在这里不太合适，我换个词。嗯，但从某种意义上说确实如此，不是吗？我的意思是，他确实在煽动人们。他确实在激起人们的情绪。他确实让人们觉得，你知道的，他让他们的血液沸腾得更快了。
Yes. All that kind of stuff. Fair enough. He says, let's say stirring. He says, I can say this to you. Either the German revolution begins tonight or we'll all be dead by dawn. You know, it's quite sort of people are all cheering and shouting. Then an absolute shambles unfolds.
是的。诸如此类的事情。好吧。那就说“煽动”吧。他说，我可以这样对你们说。要么德国革命今晚开始，要么我们在黎明前都会死。你知道的，场面相当——人们都在欢呼呐喊。然后，一场彻头彻尾的混乱上演了。
Hitler and the Nazis go off into the city determined to capture the barracks and the police headquarters and all this. And it's a complete disaster. They don't actually capture any of them. None of the army, none of the police join them at all. Meanwhile, back in the beer joined them at all. Meanwhile, back in the beer cellar, total ludicrous scenes.
希特勒和纳粹党人冲进城里，决心夺取军营、警察局和所有这些地方。结果完全是一场灾难。他们实际上没有夺取任何地方。没有一支军队，没有一个警察加入他们。与此同时，回到啤酒馆——加入他们。与此同时，回到啤酒馆，荒谬绝伦的场景。
Ludendorff, who's a military man, says to the Munich triumvirate, they say, can we go? You know, we give you our word, we'll still support the coup.
鲁登道夫是个军人，他对慕尼黑三人执政团说，他们问，我们可以走吗？你知道的，我们向你保证，我们依然会支持这场政变。
Scout's honor. And he says, oh, well, if you give me your word, of course. They go and immediately repudiate the coup completely and say we have nothing to do with this it's completely against our will they send all orders to all the army
以童子军的名誉担保。而他说，哦，好吧，既然你们向我保证，当然可以。他们离开后立刻彻底否认了这场政变，并声称我们与此毫无关系，这完全违背我们的意愿，他们向所有的军队下达指令
units do not listen to hitler and the nazis and ludendorff at all so basically by by dawn hitler is not dead nobody is dead hitler and co have trooped back rather miserably and forlornly to the beer cellar where ludendorff looking like a fool, is waiting for them. And they say, well, this hasn't gone well at all. Do they have a drink? I assume the drink's half. You'd assume. He'd be demented not to.
绝对不要听从希特勒、纳粹和鲁登道夫的话。所以基本上，到了黎明时分，希特勒没死，没人死，希特勒一行人极其狼狈、凄凉地回到了啤酒馆，鲁登道夫像个傻子一样在那里等着他们。他们说，嗯，这进展得一点都不顺利。他们喝一杯吗？我猜酒已经喝了一半了。你会这么想的。不喝的话他就疯了。
He'd be mad not to, wouldn't he? So Hitler, at this stage, I think, is still drinking. I don't think he becomes a teetotaler after he's been in prison. I might be wrong. People who know more about Hitler than I do can correct me if so. So they're back in the beer cellar. Their supporters, you know, as dawn breaks, their supporters are kind of drifting away.
不喝才怪呢，不是吗？所以我觉得，在这个阶段，希特勒还在喝酒。我不认为他在坐牢之后就成了滴酒不沾的人。我也许记错了。比我更了解希特勒的人如果我说错了可以纠正我。所以他们回到了啤酒馆。随着黎明到来，支持者们，你知道的，他们的支持者开始三三两两地散去。
It's like a party that has run out of steam. Ludendorff says, well, we have to force the issue. Let's march on the city centre. So they do. There are about 2,000 of them by this point. They set off at midday, and they're met by lines of policemen. What follows is, you know, there's a sort of confrontation, a lot of shouting, and then eventually someone starts shooting.
这就像一个开到精疲力竭的派对。鲁登道夫说，好吧，我们必须迫使局势摊牌。让我们向市中心进军。于是他们照做了。到这个时候，大约有两000人。他们在中午出发，遇到了列队的警察。接下来的事情是，你知道的，有一场对抗，许多叫喊声，然后最终有人开始开枪。
Of the leading Nazis, Goering is hit in the leg, and Hitler falls and dislocates his shoulder. He's quite lucky. Fourteen of the marchers were killed. So Hitler could have been killed and four policemen are killed of the leading nazis goering who'd been wounded he goes off to exile he's married to a swedish baroness or something so he goes off to sweden and becomes a morphine addict that is such goring behavior it's very goring behavior swedish baroness is morphine
在主要的纳粹头目中，戈林腿部中弹，希特勒摔倒并脱臼了肩膀。他算挺走运的。有十四名游行者被杀。所以希特勒本来也可能丧命，还有四名警察丧生。在主要的纳粹头目中，受伤的戈林流亡去了，他娶了一个瑞典男爵夫人什么的，所以他去了瑞典，变成了一个吗啡瘾君子。这太符合戈林的作风了。这非常戈林作风——瑞典男爵夫人加吗啡。
yeah yeah absolutely um hitler goes off to his friend. He's got a friend called Putzi Hanfstengel, who is a sort of a useless right-wing socialite. He goes off to his house and he's arrested on the 11th of November. And as every biographer of Hitler says, that absolutely should have been that for Hitler. That should have been the end of his career, this ludicrous, shambolic, failed putsch. However, there is another way of framing it, isn't there? That he had to do something like that if he was to make a successful fist of trying
对，对，绝对的……嗯，希特勒去了他的朋友那里。他有一个朋友叫普齐·汉夫施坦格尔，是个没什么用的右翼社会名流。他去了他家，并在11月11日被捕。正如希特勒的每一位传记作家所说，对希特勒来说，这绝对应该就是结局了。这本该是他政治生涯的终点，这场荒谬、混乱、失败的政变。然而，还有另一种解读方式，不是吗？那就是，如果他想通过合法的民主手段成功
to gain power through legitimate democratic means. Because he had to have demonstrated that he had the courage, the balls, the Führerprinzip that would enable him to make a bold strike. And it's only having done that that he can, you know, having demonstrated his balls, as it were, or his ball. Great historical punditry there, Tom. Well done. That he can then adopt the democratic approach. Do you think? I think it's actually a very astute point.
夺取政权，他就必须做一些类似的事情。因为他必须证明自己拥有勇气、胆识和领袖原则（Führerprinzip），这些品质能让他做出大胆的一击。只有在做到这一点之后，他才能，你知道的，在证明了自己的胆量——或者说胆识——之后，（此处有历史评论的笑话）。说得真好，汤姆，干得漂亮。他才能随后采取民主的方式。你觉得呢？我觉得这实际上是一个非常精辟的观点。
I think it means no one will ever see him as a sellout. Yeah. I mean, he's put his life on the line. Exactly. He's done what he's, you know, he has, he's risked his life for Germany. Yeah. Yeah. I think you're absolutely right, actually.
我认为这意味着没有人会再把他看作一个叛徒（sellout）。是的。我的意思是，他把自己的生命押了上去。没错。他做了他——你知道的，他为了德国甘冒生命危险。是的。是的。我觉得你绝对说得对，实际上。
I think that, I hadn't thought of it that way, but that's a very astute point that because he's done that and the beer hall is even the beer hall itself, that becomes, dare I say, a sacral space for the Nazis. Because it's shambolic, it's tawdry, you know, it's pathetic in so many ways, but it provides scope for the mythologization that will happen. And of course, the other thing that happens, am I not right, is that basically his trial provides him with a soapbox because the presiding judge is a sympathizer. Hitler agrees to carry the can for Ludendorff, who kind of sidles off.
我觉得，我之前没有从这个角度想过，但这是一个非常精辟的观点：因为他做了这件事，而且那个啤酒馆——甚至啤酒馆本身，在纳粹眼里，敢我直言，它变成了一个神圣的空间。因为它是混乱的、俗气的，你知道的，在很多方面是可悲的，但它为即将到来的神话塑造提供了空间。当然，发生的另一件事是——我没说错吧？——基本上他的审判为他提供了一个讲台，因为主审法官是个同情者。希特勒同意为鲁登道夫顶罪，而鲁登道夫则悄悄溜走了。
And he's given this, you know, he takes the stand and just has it, you know, has a rant and makes himself into a public figure. I mean, actually, I'm thinking about your point. You know, he takes the stand and just has a rant and makes himself into a public figure. Absolutely right. I mean, actually, I'm thinking about your point. Mussolini himself didn't do the march on Rome. He stayed behind, you know, in a cowardly way to see if it would work, and then went by train. Hitler actually did do this march. And presumably that then also, I mean, all his followers know this.
他得到了这个——你知道的，他走上证人席，大放厥词，把自己变成了一个公众人物。我的意思是，事实上，我正在思考你的观点。你知道，他走上证人席，大放厥词，把自己变成了一个公众人物。完全正确。我的意思是，事实上，我正在思考你的观点。墨素里尼本人并没有参与进军罗马。他留在后面，你知道的，用一种懦弱的方式观察它是否能成功，然后坐火车去的。而希特勒确实参与了这次进军。据推测，这也——我的意思是，他所有的追随者都知道这一点。
Of course. Of course. of course. He's the corporal who fought in the trenches, who then once again put his body on the line. Absolutely right. The trial, you make a really good point about the trial. The trial should have been held in Leipzig. The Bavarian authorities persuade the government to set up a special court in Munich because basically the Bavarian authorities want to cover up
当然。当然。当然。他是在战壕里战斗过的下士，然后又一次把自己的肉体押在了战场上。完全正确。关于审判，你提出了一个非常好的观点。审判本应该在莱比锡举行。巴伐利亚当局说服政府在慕尼黑设立一个特别法庭，因为基本上巴伐利亚当局想要掩盖
their own sort of half-hearted involvement in the coup. They make sure there's a judge who's a reactionary nationalist who's called Georg Neithart. There's probably, we don't know, but there's probably a deal being done where Hitler says, I'll take all, as you said, I'll carry the can completely. He goes in wearing a suit. So he looks not a uniform, but he wears his iron cross to remind everybody he's a decorated war veteran. And that quotation that you read out at the beginning,
他们自己在政变中那种半心半意的卷入。他们确保安排了一名反动民族主义法官，名叫格奥尔格·奈特哈特。可能——我们不得而知——但可能存在一笔交易，希特勒说，我会承担所有，正如你所说，我会把罪责全扛下来。他穿着西装出庭。所以他看起来没穿制服，但他佩戴着铁十字勋章，以此提醒所有人他是一位荣立战功的老兵。而你在开头读到的那段引言，
I mean, he's all talking about the court of history will judge. And he talks about it like that for four hours. I know, four hours. Imagine listening to all that for four hours. But Hitler's speeches were incredible. They'd be like two hour speeches normally.
我的意思是，他一直在谈论历史的法庭将会做出审判。他连续四个小时都在谈论这个。我知道，四个小时。想象一下听四个小时那样的演讲。但希特勒的演讲令人难以置信。它们通常就像两个小时的演讲。
Yeah. Hitler would not stop. And if you've ever read, we'll get onto Mein Kampf in a second, but if you've ever read Mein Kampf, it just goes on and on. I mean, I know I'm not one to talk in my books. It's like the worst kind of podcast. It's like, yeah, a podcast without our sort of enormous self-discipline. Exactly, and without any breaks.
是的。希特勒根本停不下来。如果你读过——我们一会儿会聊到《我的奋斗》——如果你读过《我的奋斗》，它简直没完没了。我的意思是，我知道我在自己的书里也是这样，这就像最糟糕的那种播客。就像，是的，一个没有我们这种巨大自律的播客。没错，而且没有任何中场休息。
Exactly. No ads. And without any breaks. Exactly. No ads. No ads. Yeah. So anyway, at the end of all this, Hitler is given a five-year sentence. And he is sent off to a place called Landsberg am Lech, which is an ancient kind of fortress. And this, Ian Kershaw says, basically, it's less a prison, more a hotel, which gives you a sort of sense. It's quite posh, isn't it?
没错。没有广告。而且没有任何中场休息。没错。没有广告。没有广告。是的。所以无论如何，这一切结束时，希特勒被判处五年监禁。他被送往一个叫莱希河畔兰茨贝格的地方，这是一座古老的堡垒。伊恩·克肖说，基本上，这与其说是监狱，不如说是一家酒店，这给了你一种感觉。相当高档，对吧？
It's where people have been done for fighting duels in the 90th century. Exactly. Yeah, if you're a duelist, you get sent to Landsberg, I believe. So Hitler has a big apartment there. I mean, it really is like a hotel. In the course of his time, so he's there for basically, what is it, a year or so?
那是19世纪因决斗而被捕的人去的地方。没错。是的，如果你是个决斗者，你就会被送到兰茨贝格，我相信是这样。所以希特勒在那里有一间大公寓。我的意思是，它真的就像一家酒店。在他服刑期间——基本上他在那里呆了多久，一年左右？
So the rest of it is... So he's reading, he's reading lots of racists, all that kind of stuff reading racists, what a hobby what's your hobbies so he's reading Nietzsche, Tom, like you, you've read Nietzsche I have read Nietzsche, yes
所以剩下的时间是……所以他在读书，他读了大量种族主义者的书，诸如此类，阅读种族主义者的书，真是个爱好。你的爱好是什么？所以他在读尼采，汤姆，就像你一样，你读过尼采。我确实读过尼采，是的。
well I think we should do an episode on Nietzsche and discuss how Nietzsche tends to get a clear pass from people as an influence on the Nazis but I think there is slightly more to it than that but we'll come to that maybe in another episode
嗯，我觉得我们应该做一期关于尼采的节目，讨论为什么尼采往往能毫无阻碍地被视为对纳粹有影响的人，但我认为这背后还有更多复杂的原因，不过我们可能会在另一期节目中讨论这一点。
but for the purpose of this he's reading books and then he writes one. Yes so a Nazi supporter who's a publisher called Max Amann he says why don't you write a book and Hitler basically dictates his life story to two other prisoners. So one of them is his chauffeur, a guy called Emil Morris,
但就本集而言，他在读书，然后他自己写了一本书。是的，所以一个名叫马克斯·阿曼的纳粹支持者兼出版商说，你为什么不写本书呢？于是希特勒基本上把他的生平故事口述给了其他两名囚犯。其中一个是他的司机，一个叫埃米尔·莫里斯的人，
and the other is his sort of, his poodle, his Rudolf Hess. I mean, Hess is an absolutely slavish devotee of Hitler's. I mean, Hitler has assembled this sort of group of cronies who think he's brilliant. They love listening to his speeches and they will do anything for him. That's why he even has a chauffeur. I mean, he's living off the largesse. In the 1920s, he's been living off the largesse
另一个是他的某种——他的走狗，鲁道夫·赫斯。我的意思是，赫斯是希特勒绝对盲目的崇拜者。我的意思是，希特勒聚集了这样一群心腹，他们认为他是个天才。他们喜欢听他演讲，为了他愿意做任何事。这就是为什么他甚至还有一个司机。我的意思是，他过着挥霍的生活。在20世纪20年代，他一直依靠富裕捐赠者的慷慨解囊生活。
of wealthy donors. Yeah, but it's also a kind of martyrdom, isn't it? He's suffering this for the cause of Germany, for the cause of history, for all these abstract nouns with capital letters. And so the fact that he is in prison, he is a, you know, this is paradigmatic suffering, even though he's surrounded by flowers and got all these books and visitors
是的，但这也是一种殉道，不是吗？为了德国的事业，为了历史的事业，为了所有这些带大写字母的抽象名词，他在承受这一切。因此，他在监狱里的事实，他是一个——你知道的，这是典型的痛苦，尽管他周围都是鲜花，还有各种各样的书和访客
and things. So hence his struggle. My struggle. Yeah, absolutely. And so the two themes of Mein Kampf, which is the book that he writes now, one of them is the classic old Hitler theme, and it's the hatred of the Jews. And he is absolutely, no one, as his biographers say, no one who read Mein Kampf could be in the slightest doubt about his intentions.
以及诸如此类的东西。因此就有了他的奋斗。《我的奋斗》。是的，绝对的。因此，《我的奋斗》这本书包含两个主题，这是他现在写的一本书，其中一个是希特勒经典的旧主题，那就是对犹太人的仇恨。正如他的传记作家所说，绝对没有人，任何读过《我的奋斗》的人都不会对他的意图产生一丝一毫的怀疑。
He says, you know, we will only succeed when the international poisons are exterminated. And he refers to them again and again as a virus, as maggots, as a pestilence, as a plague. He talks of annihilating, expelling, all of these kinds of things. The other thing that is more new, however, is the obsession now with Russia. So you don't see that at the beginning, the obsession with Marxism and with Russia. But now he's talking about the end of Russia as a state, about Russia being given over to the German plow. So this sort of Laban's Ram idea.
他说，你知道的，只有当国际毒瘤被消灭时，我们才能成功。他一次又一次地把他们称为病毒、蛆虫、瘟疫。他谈到要消灭、驱逐所有这些事情。然而，另一个更为主题化的新内容，是对俄罗斯的痴迷。所以在开头你并没有看到这种对马克思主义和俄罗斯的痴迷。但现在他谈论的是作为国家的俄罗斯的终结，谈论的是把俄罗斯交给德国的犁去耕耘。所以这就是生存空间（Lebensraum）的概念。
And as Richard Evans says, no one who reads this can think that Hitler is just about revising the Treaty of Versailles. Hitler is also about building a new empire in the East, about killing Jews, about turning Slavs into helots and slaves, and giving Germans living space in the steppes. And before he goes in, you described him as John the Baptist, and he was obviously playing second fiddle to Ludendorff. But does his experience in prison, his process of self-reflection, the idolization he's getting from all his various followers. Is this when he starts to think that perhaps he is the man destined to be the leader, the Fuhrer? I think absolutely. I think when he comes out of Landsberg am Lech,
正如理查德·埃文斯所说，任何读过这本书的人都不会认为希特勒仅仅是为了修改《凡尔赛条约》。希特勒还致力于在东方建立一个新的帝国，屠杀犹太人，把斯拉夫人变成黑奴和奴隶，并为德国人在草原上争取生存空间。在他入狱之前，你把他描述为施洗约翰，他当时显然在鲁登道夫手下扮演二把手。但是他在监狱里的经历，他的自我反省过程，他从各个追随者那里得到的偶像化崇拜，正是在这个时候，他开始认为自己也许就是那个注定成为领袖、元首（Fuhrer）的人吗？我觉得完全是这样。我认为当他走里昂茨河畔兰茨贝格时，
he undoubtedly thinks of himself as the leader now. There's something about that experience of maybe the putsch, but then the experience of being on trial and being the martyr, and then having these 500 guests with flowers and racist books that has puffed him up. And he thinks, I'm the man of destiny. And so this is why when he comes out, he gets everyone to, he basically refans the Nazi party, doesn't he? And he gets everyone to sign, you know,
毫无疑问，他现在认为自己就是领袖。那种经历——政变本身的经历，然后是受审并成为烈士的经历，再然后是有这500名带着鲜花和种族主义书籍的访客的经历——这一切使他膨胀了。他认为，我是命运之子。所以这就是为什么当他出来时，他让每个人都——他基本上重建了纳粹党，不是吗？他让每个人都签署，你知道的，
to swear an unconditional oath to him they do it's extraordinary scene um in kershaw says like medieval vassals swearing undying loyalty to the leader i mean they pledge themselves they pledge fealty to him so this is when you start getting the harl hitler and all that kind of stuff yeah so much more of that of course that's slightly copied on the sort of he's inherited it fromenera, who we talked about in the first podcast. But it's also all to do with that stuff about knights and a brotherhood. And of course, it's also to do with Mussolini and fascism and all the rituals of fascism. All these things, these influences flow together to create this Führer cult. And actually the Führer cult,
向他宣誓效忠。他们真的这么做了。这是一个非凡的场景。克肖说，就像中世纪的封臣向领袖发誓效忠到死一样。我的意思是，他们许下承诺，他们向他宣誓效忠。所以正是在这个时候，你开始听到“胜利万岁（Heil Hitler）”之类的话。是的，当然有更多这样的东西。当然，这有点模仿自——他是从德纳（Dernburg，此处语音模糊或指前文提到的某人，译者按语：指第一集提到的更早的组织者）那里继承来的，我们在第一期播客中讨论过。但这也与骑士和兄弟会的传说息息相关。当然，这也与墨索里尼、法西斯主义以及法西斯主义的一切仪式有关。所有这些东西，这些影响汇聚在一起，创造了这个元首崇拜。而事实上，元首崇拜——
which seems ludicrous to us and sinister, Ian Kershaw says it's really important because the Nazis had always been slightly, you know, they'd all been different factions. Yeah, well, because it's inherently vociferous, isn't it? I mean, everyone knows this about kind of eccentric political sects on the fringes, but they're always splitting up. I mean, that's the whole Judean people's front joke exactly exactly but now that they've basically sworn their loyalty to the fuhrer to the leader factionalism it doesn't come to an end of course there'll be
在我们看来既荒谬又险恶，但伊恩·克肖说这非常重要，因为纳粹内部一直有点——你知道的，他们一直存在不同的派系。是的，好吧，因为这是内在地充满争吵的，不是吗？我的意思是，边缘地区的这种古怪政治派别大家都知道这一点，但它们总是在分裂。我的意思是，这就是“犹太人民阵线”那个老笑话。完全正确，完全正确。但现在他们基本上向元首、向领袖宣誓效忠了，派系之争——虽然并没有就此结束，当然未来还会有更多的法西斯主义，但其中有一种连贯性。这就是讯息，这就是这个人，故事结束了。
more fascism to come but there's a kind of coherence there this is the message this is the guy end of story but isn't isn't there also walking with destiny something else that hitler has got from this is this idea that there can be no march on berlin because it hasn't worked it won't work and therefore there's this idea that he will destroy democracy through democratic means yeah you're absolutely right which is a chilling thing and has been a chilling thing ever since. Well, that's what makes him so unsettling for people living in a democracy to this day. All democracies have to contend with that. What happens when you have somebody who doesn't play by the rules? Yeah.
但是，迎着命运前行，希特勒从中得到的还有别的东西，不是吗？就是这个想法：不能再有进军柏林了，因为那没有奏效，也行不通，因此产生了一个新想法：他将通过民主手段来摧毁民主？是的，你完全说对了，这真是一件令人不寒而栗的事情，并且自那以后一直是一件令人不寒而栗的事情。嗯，这就是为什么生活在民主制度中的人至今仍对感到他如此不安。所有的民主国家都必须应对这一点。当出现一个不按规则出牌的人时，会发生什么？是的。
And so what is the state of the Weimar democracy by this point? So what kind of 19, early 1925? Yeah. So now we have a series of steps. We're going to have them in the last few minutes of this podcast and then particularly in the next episode. A series of steps
那么，此时魏玛民主制度的状况如何？也就是说，大约在1925年初是什么样？是的。现在我们有一系列步骤。我们将在本期播客的最后几分钟以及接下来的那一集里详细探讨。一系列的步骤，
whereby the guardians of the Weimar Republic, the very people who should be protecting it, start to dismantle it, start to sign, in some cases, to sign their own death warrants. The first moment, it's bad luck. It's really bad luck.
通过这些步骤，魏玛共和国的守护者们，那些本应保护它的人，开始拆除它，在某些情况下，开始签署他们自己的死刑令。第一个时刻，纯属运气不好。这真的是运气不好。
Friedrich Ebert, the president, the guy who was synonymous with Weimar. So the Clement Attlee of Weimar. Exactly. The Clement Attlee as I described him. He dies of appendicitis. He's neglected it too long. He's under tremendous pressure, horrendous abuse in the newspapers. He neglects it. He dies of appendicitis um this is a disaster for weimar they then have a presidential election ludendorff actually runs he gets one percent um that's the end of him but his partner in the first world war his sort of dictatorial partner
弗里德里希·艾伯特，总统，那个与魏玛同义的人——魏玛的克莱门特·艾德礼。没错。正如我所形容的魏玛的克莱门特·艾德礼。他死于阑尾炎。他拖延太久没去理会。他承受着巨大的压力，报纸上对他进行了可怕的辱骂。他忽略了病情。他死于阑尾炎——这对魏玛来说是一场灾难。他们随后举行了总统大选，鲁登道夫居然参选了，他获得了百分之一的选票——这宣告了他的政治生命结束。但他在第一次世界大战中的搭档，他那种独裁风格的搭档——
paul von hindenburg who is this sort of he looks like he's been chiseled out of a massive Prussian... Kind of Prussian walrus. Yeah, Prussian walrus. Massive moustache, giant head. I imagine he wears a helmet with a spike in the bath. Yeah, he's like a square man who's been cut out
保罗·冯·普鲁士……保罗·冯·兴登堡，他看起来就像是用一块巨大的普鲁士……某种普鲁士海象雕刻出来的。是的，普鲁士海象。巨大的胡子，巨大的脑袋。我猜他在洗澡时戴着带尖顶的头盔。是的，他就像一个从木头里切割出来的方头人。
of wood. Very reactionary, very, you know, monarchist, doesn't really believe in Weimar. He actually seeks permission from the Kaiser before he throws his hat in the presidential ring. He doesn't even run the first round. He's co-opted, runs in the second round. He's 78 years old.
非常反动，非常——你知道的，保皇党，并不真正相信魏玛。他在把自己的帽子扔进总统竞选的竞技场之前，甚至还向德皇寻求了许可。他甚至没有参加第一轮竞选。他是被推选出来的，参加了第二轮竞选。他当时78岁。
He becomes the president of Germany. And he and his circle, so he's surrounded by kind of cronies, particularly army advisors. None of them are keen on democracy. None of them are keen on Weimar. They're basically itching to destroy it. That is a disaster for Weimar. Meanwhile, the Nazis, so these are supposedly the golden years
他成为了德国总统。他和他的圈子——所以他被一群心腹环绕，尤其是军队顾问。他们没有一个人热衷于民主。没有一个人热衷于魏玛。他们基本上渴望摧毁它。这对魏玛来说是一场灾难。与此同时，纳粹——所以这些被认为是魏玛共和国的黄金岁月，最后的几年，因为通货膨胀结束了。经济情况稍微好一点了。纳粹党虽然规模非常小，但开始不断发展，
of the Weimar Republic, the last years, because the inflation is over. The economy is doing a little bit better. The Nazi party is actually although it's very small it's beginning to grow and and the key thing that it does is that it it moves out so it's been in munich in bavaria which is very very as you all know tom very very catholic and where institutionally there's a lot of kind of there's an obvious resistance to hitler's message because the Catholic Church is very strong. Well, because Munich is a kind of,
而它所做的关键事情是，它走出了慕尼黑——它之前一直在巴伐利亚的慕尼黑，正如你们所有人所知，汤姆，那里非常非常天主教化，而且在体制上对希特勒的讯息有着明显的抗拒，因为天主教教会非常强大。嗯，因为慕尼黑是一个政治动荡的孤岛，四周被天主教农民群体包围，基本上是这样的。是的。但他们开始做的是在德国北部的路德宗（新教）地区建立支持。
it's an island of political turbulence surrounded by Catholic peasantry, basically. Yes. But what they start to do is to build support in the Protestant north of Germany. Which they have to do, don't they, if they're going to become national because there are far more Protestants in Germany than
如果他们想成为一个全国性的政党，他们就必须这样做，不是吗？因为德国的新教徒远多于天主教徒。完全同意。这里有一个关键人物，有一个人叫格雷戈尔·施特莱瑟。在纳粹党内，他算是希特勒意识形态上的竞争对手，如果你愿意这么说的话。他是另一个聪明人。他肯定比……
Catholics. Agreed. There's a key figure here, there's a man called Gregor Strasser. He's sort of Hitler's ideological rival, if you like, in the Nazi party. He's the other guy who's clever. He's certainly cleverer than... But not in the long
但从长远来看，在纳粹党内做希特勒的意识形态对手可不是一件好事。一点也不是。他是个出色的组织者。他是个出色的行政管理者。当希特勒在监狱里时，他一直在建立和发展这个党。当施特莱瑟走遍德国北部时，他不仅强调民族主义，也强调社会主义。
run a good thing to be an ideological rival to Hitler in the Nazi party. Not at all. He's a brilliant organizer. He's a brilliant administrator. He's been sort of building it up while Hitler was in prison. And when he goes around North Germany, Strasse, he emphasizes the socialism as well as the national.
是的。所以他与产业工人交谈，因为德国北部工业非常发达，他在那里与人们交谈并说道，你知道的，你们将获得更高的工资，你们将拥有更好的生活标准，我们将保护你们的工作条件，所有这些东西。所以他实际上是把戈培尔——约瑟夫·戈培尔引入党内的人。戈培尔来自工业化的莱茵兰，他是个天主教徒，是个天主教徒，是的，他拥有海德堡大学浪漫主义戏剧博士学位。
Yeah. So he talks to industrial workers, because it's very industrial in North Germany, and he talks to people there and he says, you know, you'll have higher wages, you'll have better living standards we'll protect your working conditions all this stuff so he he's the guy really who brings in goebbels joseph goebbels goebbels is from the industrial rhineland he's a catholic he is a catholic yeah he has a phd from heidelberg on romantic drama yeah what do you believe i didn't know what goebbels was a doctor of and
真的吗？我不知道戈培尔是什么博士，而且——这听起来很不符合常理，但戈培尔相当具有波希米亚风格，他其实曾被极左翼和极右翼所吸引，他读过马克思的书……他搭上了施特莱瑟的关系，他是一个真正的宣传家。所以——我的意思是，人们对戈培尔有两点评价：一是他的戏剧感，对吧，你提到了浪漫主义戏剧；其次，首先他是天主教徒，所以有一种你知道的——教会的展示以及所有那些东西；但其次，正是因为他出身于这种戏剧背景，从某种意义上说，纳粹最终把德国变成了一个用于进行不可思议的盛大庆典和炫耀的舞台，这显然是纳粹吸引力的一部分，因为他们在宣传呈现方面并不无聊。而戈培尔在这方面非常出色。
it seems very implausible but he's quite bohemian goebbels and he had actually been drawn to the far left and the far right he'd read marx um he gets in with strasser he's a real propagandist so so i mean people say two things about goebbels sense of theatrical yeah and you say a romantic drama firstly that he's catholic so there's the sense of the you know the uh the church display and all that kind of stuff but secondly precisely that he is he he comes from this theatrical milieu that he in a sense he the nazis end up making germany a stage for incredible pageantry and swagger and that is obviously part of the appeal of the Nazis is that they're not boring in terms of their projection. And Goebbels is brilliant at that.
是的，你完全说对了。当然，你真的需要观看《意志的胜利》，莱尼·里芬施塔尔的电影，就会知道他们一点也不无聊。但施特莱瑟和戈培尔所做的是，他们非常擅长将吸引力扩大到那些实际上相当无趣的人群中。特别是农民，德国北部农村地区的那些人，当时正遭遇农业萧条。不过戈培尔后来去了柏林，对吧？
Yeah, you're absolutely right. Of course, you really need to watch Triumph of the Will, Lenny Riefenstahl's film, to know that they're not boring. But what Strauss and Goebbels do, they're very good at broadening its appeal to actually quite boring people. So particularly farmers, the sort of people in the countryside in North Germany, there's an agricultural depression. But Goebbels goes to Berlin though, doesn't he?
所以他成了柏林的盖世太保大区长官（Gauleiter）。是的，但那是很久以后了。那是后来，是吗？对的。是的。目前，他还在施特莱瑟和希特勒之间稍微有些摇摆不定。但他们在做的是，在这些农村地区发起招募运动，比如石勒苏益格-荷尔斯泰因、奥尔登堡。所以，尽管纳粹党在总体上表现得很糟糕——
So he becomes the Gauleiter in Berlin. Yeah, but much later on. That's later, is it? Right. Yeah. At the moment, he's sort of torn between Strasser and Hitler a little bit. But what they're doing, they're launching recruiting drives in these sort of rural places, Schleswig-Holstein, Oldenburg. So even though they do really badly, generally, the Nazis,
在1928年的国会选举中，他们获得的选票不到百分之三。他们只得到了12个议席。施特莱瑟是一个。戈培尔是一个。戈林是一个。他们在这些新教农业地区表现得越来越好。他们提供什么？他们的宣传点是什么？所以宣传点是，我们将——宣传点是，我们会倾听你们的声音，没有其他人愿意听。我的意思是，社会民主党是一个城市政党……民族主义者，右翼政党，他们是权贵阶层、富人的政党、中产阶级政党。
in the 1928 Reichstag elections, they win less than 3% of the vote. They only get 12 deputies. Strasser is one. Goebbels is one. Goering is one. They're actually doing better and better in these kind of protestant agriculture what are they offering what's the pitch so the pitch is we will the pitch is we will listen to you nobody else is listening i mean the social democrats are city party um the nationalists the right- party. They are a bigwigs establishment, rich people's party, middle-class party.
纳粹则在宣称，他们把自己重新包装为一个真正的全国性政党，为所有人提供利益，尤其是为那些被时代抛弃的人。而新教乡村地区感觉自己被抛弃了。他们说，我们将建立农民合作社。我们会认真对待农民。因此，他们正在向农民以及像他们这样的人群——手艺人、工匠、店主、自谋职业者伸出援手。他们说，我们将让德国再次伟大。我们会倾听你们的声音。我们会让经济走上正轨。你们会得到更好的报酬，并且你们会再次为身为德国人感到骄傲。
The Nazis are saying they're rebranding themselves as a genuinely national party with something for everybody, and particularly for those who've been left behind. And the sort of Protestant countryside feels like it has been left behind. They say we'll set up farmers cooperatives. We'll take farmers seriously. So they are reaching out to farmers and people like them, craftsmen, artisans, shopkeepers, the self-employed. And they're saying, we'll make Germany great again. We'll listen to you. We'll put the economy on an even keel. You'll be better paid, but you'll feel proud to be German
没有人再为身为德国人感到自豪了。顺便说一句，他们对年轻人有着特别强的吸引力。因为，当然，如果你很年轻，如果你没有经历过，如果你没有在一战中战斗过，你就会有一种轻微的内疚感，你希望自己曾经参与过，你错过了它。但你也经历了一次又一次的危机。这方面的一个好例子是一个年轻人，一个聪明的年轻人，出生在慕尼黑。
again. No one feels proud to be German anymore. They particularly have a strong appeal, by the way, to young people. Because, of course, if you're young, if you didn't live through, if you didn't fight in the First World War, you have a slight sense of guilt and you wish you'd done it, you missed out on it. But you've also been through crisis after crisis. A good example of that is a young man, a bright young man, who was born in Munich.
他的父亲是一名天主教学校教师，出生于1900年，从未在第一次世界大战中见证过战斗，聪明，在一战后完成了学业，被卷入了极右翼圈子。他就是海因里希·希姆莱。所以希姆莱，我的意思是，我们大多数人会认为他是人类历史上最险恶的人物之一，他在1925年加入了纳粹党。他狂热地崇拜希特勒。我的意思是，希姆莱把所有这些狂热都带到了桌面上，不是吗？所有那些疯狂的神秘主义东西等等。是的。草药学。图勒学会。
His father was a Catholic schoolteacher, who was born in 1900, never got to see action in the First World War, clever, studied after the First World War, sucked into the far right scene. And he's Heinrich Himmler. So Himmler, I mean, who most of us would regard as one of the most sinister men who's ever lived, he joined the Nazi party in 1925. He hero worships Hitler. I mean, Himmler brings to the table all of these enthusiasms, doesn't he? All the kind of mad occult stuff and everything. Yeah. Herbalism. The Thule society.
符文，所有这些。还有非常非常激进的种族主义。我的意思是，说这是一个如此邪恶的人听起来很奇怪，但希姆莱身上有一种理想主义。我的意思是，他崇拜希特勒，作为一个年轻人，他认为这是通往乌托邦的道路，他认为一切都是垃圾和俗气的，当然，因为纳粹并不认为自己是邪恶的。纳粹认为自己正在做对德国和他们的种族正确的事情。你必须完成那种跨越，试图去理解他们是如何看待自己的，否则你就无法理解他们吸引力的本质。是的。我的意思是，他们不认为自己是邪恶的。
Runes, all of that. And also very, very radical racism. I mean, it seems weird to say this is such a wicked man there is an idealism to himmler i mean he worships hitler he thinks as a young man he thinks this is the the root to the utopia this is everything is rubbish and tawdry of course because the nazis don't see themselves as evil. The Nazis see themselves doing what is right for Germany and for their race. And you have to make that leap of trying to see them as they see themselves, or else you won't understand the nature of their appeal. Yeah. I mean, they don't see themselves as wicked.
不，他们甚至不觉得——当然，他们不认为自己的反犹太主义是邪恶的。不，因为他们认为这是为了德国人民的利益。是的。但当然，在这一点上，他们规模还很小。他们仍然是一个边缘政党。他们虽然在这些新教农村地区不断壮大，但距离成为一个主要政党还有很长的路要走。我的意思是，主要的政党实际上组成了一个大联合政府，即社会民主党、天主教中央党和自由民主党。
No, they don't even see that. I mean, certainly they don't see their antisemitism as wicked. No, because they see it as being for the good of the German people. Yeah. But of course, at this point, they are small. They're still a fringe party. They are growing in these sort of Protestant rural areas, but they're still a long way from being a major party. I mean, the big parties are in a grand coalition, actually, the Social Democrats, the Catholic Centre Party, and the Liberal Democrats Party.
在那个时候没有任何理由——在1928年左右，没有人认真认为五年之内纳粹就会成为主人。好吧，我们是否可以用理查德·埃文斯的一段话来结束今天的节目？好的，来吧，汤姆。好的。
And there's no reason at that point, nobody in sort of 1928 or so, seriously thinks that within five years, the Nazis will be the masters. Okay, well, shall we leave today's episode with a passage from Richard Evans? Yeah, go for it, Tom. Okay. It would need a catastrophe of major dimensions if an extremist party like the Nazis was to gain mass support.
“如果一个像纳粹这样的极端政党要获得大众的支持，就需要一场重大规模的灾难。”
In 1929, with the sudden collapse of the economy in the wake of the stock exchange crash in New York, it came. Goodbye. We'll see you next time. Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde.
1929年，随着纽约股市崩溃后经济的突然崩盘，灾难真的来了。再见。我们下期节目再见。再见。感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听独家节目、提前解锁、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请访问 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德。
And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q our q a we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad-free listening bonus episodes and early There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、少量秀场八卦的固定栏目。在我们的问答环节中，我们拉开了娱乐业的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚启动了会员俱乐部，如果你想要无广告收听、额外节目和提前……本期节目还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可留下评论。